the symbol for momentum is is a vector
quantity so it has a bold face and it's
p
either big p or little p i have no idea
why impulse or momentum it's just got
that symbol p i mean why has current got
a symbol i i mean we just run out of
letters after a while and make something
up
i've got a track here made by george and
first of all i want to show you that you
get a ball rolling down the slope and
when it's level it has a constant
momentum
and now
one on the left is winning the one on
the left and they're slowly going up the
slope and i didn't do that properly
because they should have arrived at the
same time but it's not perfect
now then i'm going to put
several balls in a row
there's another one over there excuse me
can i
adjust my balls these four balls are
just touching and i'm going to get this
other ball to come in and
hit it with certain momentum the
momentum is going to be transferred down
the chain of balls and this one will fly
off but people buy newton's cradle and
the thing swings down and the other one
comes off so i just want to show you the
effective momentum on this and you can
see what happens
and these move forward a little bit and
then that rolls back there's a lot of
bit of energy as they smack together
because some sound comes out so that's
what happens if you have these steel
balls in a row now we're going to take
this neodymium magnet really strong
magnet and put it in the front so the
ball will now come down and smash into
this and transfer the momentum through
only it's
a very strong magnet as you can see it
just sucks them all together
and so they're now all in a row i'm
about to take this away the ball will
roll down
and hit into this magnet and then i'd
like you to film particularly what
happens afterwards
wow
wow
anyway that works because this is such a
strong magnet now this one on the end i
can pull off quite easily as you can see
it's not stuck so strongly this one
i can't take off
easily there's a very very very strong
force that pulls this in
and as it gets closer
um
it's suddenly pulled in and so you get a
tremendous acceleration just as it hits
it and it comes in with much higher
speed than you imagine because of the
magnetic attraction the one on the other
end is not stuck so strongly i can take
it away quite easily the next one is is
just about possible so as it rolls down
the slope it gets to a nice reasonable
speed and rolls along here with a
constant momentum but when it comes
towards that
magnet it suddenly gets pulled in
dramatically
and it has much more of a momentum as it
arrives because a force
gives change to the momentum and
accelerates it smashes in there and that
momentum is transferred to this ball
when when this one leaves why wasn't it
pulled back to the magnet canceling out
yes you would have thought that it would
have done that and if you put less on
they it will do something like that but
what happens is that magnetic field here
is very strong weaker here weaker here
and
weaker there so it can easily break away
so as it comes in it pushes this they
all go forward a bit but this one breaks
away at high speed so
what's happened is there's a change in
the momentum but also this comes in with
enormous energy so the party that comes
off has enormous energy as well so it's
much much faster than you think if you
film this backwards it would seem more
realistic because you would have a
particle coming in hitting that and
something dribbling out at the other
side because it's the other way around
it looks stunning as though it's filmed
in reverse but it's not that's how it
was done
you were a witness you saw it we could
do it again if you want
what you see when it's played back
really slowly is the particle coming in
very slowly sedately and then suddenly
just as it approaches the magnet it
suddenly accelerates and becomes a blur
because it's sucked in so hard because
this is such a strong magnet and it's
that sudden impulse that sudden kick
that it's getting from the magnetic
field pulling it in that leads to the
other particles flying off you can see
that if i let that come in here and
smash
there's a lot of work that i have to do
to pull that off i mean
i am an old man but you know this is
just about doable pulling it away it
requires a lot of work and it's that
work
that you'd have to do to get this to be
a perpetual motion machine that's going
to kill you because this work is too
much and that doesn't get all that
energy coming out the other side so it
seems as though you're getting something
for nothing but the problem is you've
got to pull the balls off